la société industrielle occidentale n'a pas
vraiment valorisé la forêt boréale si vous
ne pouvez pas l'abattre et en faire un deux par quatre
ou trouver de l'or ou quelque chose
dans une roche qui se trouve en dessous, nous sommes
ici pour dire que c'est  une très mauvaise
attitude à avoir à l'égard de la forêt boréale
et du fait qu'il y a tout un trésor de
plantes, de tous les animaux et de
tout ce qui fait partie de l'écosystème
qui est très très précieux
[Musique]
euh, je m'appelle Randy Johns, je suis le
gestionnaire de la forêt boréale Heartland
produits à base de plantes ce que nous faisons, c'est que nous travaillons avec
des produits forestiers non ligneux provenant de la
forêt boréale. Les produits forestiers non ligneux
sont à peu près tout ce qui se trouve dans la forêt,
ce qui n'est pas un deux par quatre, tout est
à peu près récolté à la main par la population locale,
tous les moissonneurs.  sont autochtones et
nous sommes une entreprise autochtone. Je suis en fait
la seule personne non autochtone qui
travaille dans l'entreprise. Le Royal Heartland
appartient à la Kuweitan Community
Development Association, une
organisation à but non lucratif. Beaucoup de
gens vendent le Boreal.  Heartland,
ils n'ont peut-être pas d'autre travail, donc nous
donnons à beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas
beaucoup d'opportunités une chance de
gagner respectueusement le respect d'eux-mêmes
et de gagner de l'argent pour
eux-mêmes
grâce à Internet.
à quoi ressemble notre récolte
tout au long de l'année et ensuite nous
disons aux gens quand c'est la saison de
récolter parce que tout n'est pas de
saison en même temps, alors les gens
sortent et ils cueilleront des cynorrhodons,
les apporteront un peu  à la fois, cinq
livres, 10 livres, peut-être 20 livres et nous
proposons une formation car il y a
une certaine identification des plantes et des choses
que les gens doivent savoir pour récolter
de manière durable,
c'est ainsi que nous avons commencé à tout sécher,
ce sont des constructions très simples dans lesquelles
nous les construisons, euh,
d'autres communautés également et c'est une
conception locale, vous savez, nous ne savions pas
quel genre de hangar construire quand nous avons
commencé,
mais euh, nous, on nous a donné des
couvertures de serre d'occasion, ils ne
veulent pas jeter le plastique.  et nous
prenons le plastique et nous l'utilisons pendant
encore quelques années
nous voulons préserver l'état naturel de
la forêt si vous allez
récolter à Wildcraft dans une zone vous ne
prenez qu'un tiers de la plante comme si
vous  Nous cueillons les feuilles d'une plante au
maximum un tiers des feuilles de la
plante, donc l'idée est un tiers pour vous,
un tiers pour que la plante se
reproduise et un tiers pour
tous les autres animaux qui sont absents.  voilà
donc c'est l'idée de la façon dont nous pouvons
tous vivre ensemble et être durables
[Musique]
nous avons accumulé des connaissances
afin de faire ce business et puis il
y a beaucoup de connaissances que les gens locaux
ont toutes sortes de connaissances collectives
sur  de la région et des plantes,
etc., mais personne ne sait
tout, donc c'est un échange d'apprentissage
et donc pour les peuples autochtones, c'est une
chance de se reconnecter à l'
environnement. La plupart des gens
ici sont des Denny coréens, etc.  ils sont
ici depuis des milliers d'années
et donc c'est leur patrie
et c'est très positif pour la
communauté
malheureusement de moins en moins de gens sont
engagés dans la terre alors peut-être que leurs
grands-parents y allaient plus
régulièrement et  peut-être que les petits-enfants
ne le font pas, mais cela donne une chance aux grands-parents
et aux parents de transmettre
une partie de ces connaissances pour sortir dans
l'environnement et transmettre leurs
connaissances à la jeune
génération. Nous sommes donc très heureux de pouvoir le faire.
peut en faire partie,
donc celui-ci est euh Thé à l'
épilobe L'épilobe est une plante qui
pousse très abondamment dans la
forêt boréale, elle fait un bon thé noir et savoureux
pour les assaisonnements, nous les broyons très
bien et vous pouvez ensuite utiliser de la poudre d'églantier
pour  aromatisant et c'est une très belle couleur
pour quelque chose comme le riz cette année, la
récolte a été si abondante pour les cynorhodons,
il y en avait tellement.
J'ai grandi dans une petite ferme dans le sud de la
Saskatchewan et j'ai appris des petites
compétences agricoles quand j'étais un
enfant et donc pour moi, c'est un
aspect de la réconciliation. J'ai mentionné
que je ne suis pas autochtone afin que je puisse transmettre
certaines de ces choses que j'ai
apprises quand j'étais enfant, de la
culture des colons aux peuples autochtones en termes de
leur  réengagement avec l'
environnement naturel et avec leurs traditions
donc pour moi c'est quelque chose qui, euh,
je suis dans une position unique et j'en suis très
reconnaissant